The joe rogan experience.
I studied musical theater.
Did you?
Yeah.
So you've got a bang actresses.
It was the best.
It was.
It was like they only took 20 kids a year into the course.
3000 people auditioned.
Whoa.
Right.
It was like a very prestigious thing.
It was the same course of Hugh Jackman did and there was an acting paper.
I could not good enough so I can sing a bit.
So I got in the musical theater thing and I could back in the day.
Yeah.
You sing now.
No soundtrack to legit.
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you something about me.
You might not know.
That's a little fact about me.
I Sang,
I sang twice in the Australian opera,
in the course as an employed opera singer.
Yeah.
Wow.
I was like,
what kind of like what it became was a little,
I was,
I've had,
I've had vocal nodules.
I've had surgery on my voice.
I can't over,
I'm not making it up though.
I,
I sang in a,
Charles Green was Romeo and Juliet and Wagner as the flying Dutchman as course
vocal nodules.
Um,
pull ups on your vocal chords.
Basically calluses from smoking coke.
A yelling is mostly from yelling from the bashing together and they get
calluses.
So you can actually get your vocal cords close enough together to make high
sounds because there's always a gap in him from these little things.
So it makes you a man.
It's like a noodles.
He'll fucking man.
It's what it is.
Yeah.
Well I guess of course
John Wayne's voice came from exactly.
It's like these,
these grisled comedians who have yelled on stage or times cause there that is
covered like the,
you know,
what else is bad?
Like these white Bobby Slayton popped up.
I'm telling you,
that guy,
his vocal cords is just,
just a nodule or nodular.
I'm telling you,
he might've had a vocal surgery if I'm,
I might be wrong,
but I've,
I've heard of comedians that have had that before.
It's more than why I had this before.
I was a comedian to try to save the Singing Korea.
So he had surgery on the pollups.
Yeah.
So they shaved down the cows,
couldn't,
couldn't talk for a,
couldn't talk for two months.
Oh my God,
two months.
Yeah,
just riding on a fucking pad.
Oh,
that was what that was when I thought,
this job,
I'm going to get these back because I partied too much.
And then I thought,
I've got no other skills.
I've got no other skills in the fucking world.
And I decided I always wanted to be a comedian,
but it wasn't a job that my parents would never let me do,
or it wouldn't let you do that.
He said it wasn't,
my parents were happy with the musical theater because they saw what my mother
could brag and act like.
It was a bit more light.
He die then the whole thing.
But I decided I was going to be a comedian in that two months where I couldn't
talk.
I was like a secret that I had to myself.
Like,
that's fucking awesome.
And I had already,
I was,
I was like checking out what were the open mics were in.
Howard just started watching a lot of standup,
the videos and,
and that's what I did,
you know,
living by myself,
not talking for a couple of months.
That's fucking awesome.
And,
uh,
what was I talking about before with the,
Oh,
the great thing about the cost though.
So 10 boys,
10,
10 girls.
Uh,
uh,
and there was to e cheese above us.
So there's three years.
So there was,
it was like 90 people in the whole sort of department
half,
uh,
80% of the men would guy right in the course.
Let's study musical theater.
So we had [inaudible] guys and to heterosexuals,
all the women were fucking hot as fuck.
We're like,
like been dancing since I was a kid and just seeing in fucking night and that we
were all like 20.
It was the best thing ever.
I even is the reasonable looking fucking heterosexual guy because it was
fantastic.
Now one of the,
the,
the mind girls in the course was a go cold.
Uh,
Shantelle Barry and Chantel was going was the one that we were all like,
she's going to be a star.
She was stunning.
You can look her up on the net.
She was fucking stunning.
She could sing better than everyone else.
She could.
She was,
she had everything is go right.
And then they brought out the first version of like pop auto or American auto or
whatever that it was done in Australia first and was called a miking.
The band or whatever real they show it was actually originated in New Zealand,
but then in Australia they might just go bang,
called Bardo were all the people came in and auditioned to be in his goal band.
And the goal that I was at university,
she went to this audition for this TV show she got in the band,
but they played it over weeks and weeks and weeks and they had cameras in the
house.
And it was the first reality,
big reality show ever where we were watching these people just living in a house
and people couldn't fathom whether there's no act as this is real.
It was like a very,
there,
she's there.
Yeah.
Anyway,
so,
uh,
I used to stand behind her stretching and dance class every and just fucking,
just all I wanted was to have sex with this young lady.
Never happened.
Right.
So anyway,
so she gets in his band and she stills the story guy.
She stills on a 10 or $20 out of one of the other girls who were in the bands a
bag and she gets cooked cause it's fucking cameras everywhere.
So she's got this big opportunity.
Everyone else who was in this band has gone on to big things like Sophie monk is
the model out here dated Ryan Seacrest for while she was one of the other girls
in the band and now does big modeling in his movies and Shit.
Right.
So he shan't tell gets kicked out of the fucking bank.
All over.
Right.
So she moves over.
She's bad press in Australia.
They're all really slagging her off and what type of stuff?
She was sort of a friend and she,
she moved over to La and I remember like looking at a myspace page like wow,
she's made in an ally.
She was backup singing for Lionel Richie or something.
Right.
Like got everything worked out for,
right.
Cut to first season of legit.
We need a goal and a saint that he's just hot girl number two,
right.
She comes into the audition.
I went fucking hell.
Shantelle she didn't recognize me or remember me at all and I said,
oh wait,
where's your accent from him?
And then I started saying the suburb she was from from at this and you have two
older sisters?
Yeah.
You look like someone who has two to,
cause I used to party it ass Cisco and I got you got a butterfly tattoo just
above your ass.
Just stuff that she goes.
Yeah.
And I,
when I went away,
went to university together.
Right.
And then she went,
oh did we find,
and then I went,
all right,
give her the pot.
Right.
Because I'm a good guy.
The pot had like one line and then she came on set.
And I think in that moment,
this is how much of an ocelot must be.
She remembered who I was from school
when she came on,
since he came on set,
she was like,
cause Jim Jeffrey,
I have my real last name is Nugent.
I use my middle name as a stage name because of Ted.
No,
I just did.
Jim Jefferies sounded better than Jim Nugent.
Jim Jeffrey,
you know what I mean?
It was just,
it was a little tiny thing to with alliteration,
you know?
Right.
And so she'll,
she,
I wasn't going by my original name,
so she had no reasons.
Right.
And then I sort of reminded,
I said,
how he used to come over and your mommy's to make this type of food and blah
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
I think she was so pissed off that I made it and she didn't.
And I had my own TV show that uh,
she went up to the producer and went,
ah,
I've got food poisoning.
I need to go home and just walked off the set.
What didn't even do the job?
Maybe she's just kinda little squirt.
Maybe she had to leave.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
We really
didn't take the Gig man.
What makes you think that it's because of that?
I just think it's,
I just think people get fucking jealous,
man.
We all get jealous.
I think she just was like,
fuck this can cause I was the guy at university that you thought wouldn't make
it.
All the other gay guys had abs and stuff and I was like a bit of a doorway
fucking marshmallow looking kind of who could sing a little bit,
who couldn't dance at all and was acting was pretty average.
I always kicked out like five people a year from the course,
like,
you're not good enough.
I left after I got the nodules and I knew I was gonna get kicked out.
Anyway,
that was hard.
He rod on the cards.
I walked before I jumped before I was pushed.
That competitive thing of show business is one of the weirdest aspects of it.
Yeah.
Sometimes even in relationships.
I had a friend who got something and his girlfriend started crying when he got
some part in some TV show and his girlfriend started crying because she was
like,
well,
something's going to happen for me.
Like that was her immediate reaction and I remember thinking,
wow,
I got to get rid of that,
but here's something that's about to happen to you.
I'm was,
yeah,
that that,
that's a very unattractive,
that competitive things.
He can't help it a little bit.
With comedy.
It's very hard to never have it with any other stope comic.
There's always going to be one where you go that guy.
But I,
I I found out now and I think it's easier because I got a bit of success,
but I don't give a shit what any,
I just worry about me.
I don't give a fuck if someone's got a movie or something.
I don't give a fuck.
I just worry about me.
And then you know,
the good guys,
you know the bad guys and that's it.
But when in the early days it was more,
I got more jealous at has that going at that club.
I've been trying to get into that club forever.
That's just the frustration of not having made it yet.
And then once you have and you've got some success,
it goes away and then you can actually enjoy it for what it is.
I think the successful people who are still fucking don't want anything other,
well there's a lot of successful people also that only work with terrible
comedian so that they shine.
Have you ever seen like a really good guy that brings like the fucking worst
guys ever on the road to open forum?
Torch is the audience for a half an hour with the worst fucking shit standup
ever.
Just so they can come in and clean up the show and look like a hero.
And that's really what it is.
They don't want anybody to shine.
That's a very,
we need a common,
yeah,
it's common,
but it's,
yeah.
I always sang.
I like his,
uh,
chase the dream that the competition.
It's a good saying.
Yeah.